weighing up these factors their minimum
term in your case Stephen Bowden will be
29 years
from that you must have deducted the
number of days you have already spent in
custody which I'm told is 519 Days
please can Stephen Bowden be taken down
weighing up these factors the minimum
term in your case Shannon Marsden will
be 27 years
from that you must have deducted the
number of days you've already spent in
custody which I'm told is 519 Days
please can Shannon Marsden be taken down
right you are watching the sentencing of
Stephen Marsden Stephen Bowden and
Shannon Marsden for the murder of their
10-month-old son Finley Bowden which
occurred in 2020 Christmas day of 2020.
as we heard there the judge sentencing
Stephen Bowden to 29 years minimum
sentence and Shannon Marsden 27 years